those nominated for the best performance
as an actor in a supporting role are
Vincent gardenia for bang the drum
slowly Jack Guildford for save the tiger
John Houseman for paper moon Paper Chase
Jason Miller for The Exorcist
Randy Quaid for the last picture show of
the last detail and the winner is John
Houseman in the Paper Chase
almost the first time in a long and
tumultuous life I'm almost speechless I
cannot possibly describe to the emotions
which I receive this great honor at your
hands but I do have a few personal
gratitude that I would like to express
for all those who worked me on the Paper
Chase to their great kindness and
generosity at the appearing at the
appearance of a mysterious intruder in
their midst for Gordon Willis whose
extraordinarily dramatic camerawork did
a great deal to create the character of
dr. King's field and thirdly fourthly
and fifthly to my dear friend Jim
Bridges as a writer as the director and
as the extraordinarily reckless young
man who had the unspeakable gall to
select an aging and obscure schoolmaster
to play this perfectly glorious part
you